unemployment unexpectedly drops and some
Democrats are upset about it the New
York Times's woke staffers destroyit sob
page to stop a conservative column and
drew breezes atonement is rejected i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn dot-com / then
all righty so the big story of the
morning is that the unemployment rate
shockingly declined to 13.3% there are a
lot of people who are expecting most of
the economists we're expecting an
addition of some 7.5 million people to
the unemployment rolls this month
instead it turns out that unemployment
actually decreased by 2.5 million Dow
Jones experts according to Daily wire
had predicted the rate would soared in
nineteen point five percent with another
8 million jobs lost the economists were
not even close the economy actually
created more than 2.5 million jobs in
May according to the Labor Department
the Megane was the biggest one-month
jobs gained in American history since at
least 1939 President Trump wrote on
Twitter it's a stunner by any stretch of
the imagination it's a stupendous number
it's joyous let's call it like it is the
market was right it's stunning jobs
returned too many sectors from retail
sales to restaurants and bars to
clothing stores to dentistry in medical
practices jobs were lost in government
and education doing too due to ongoing
school closures futures on the Dow
soared more than 650 points on the good
news the unemployment rate increased by
more than 10 percent in April 1 all the
way up to 14 point 7 percent the March
jobs report barely caught the initial
surge in unemployment it was just then
at 4.4 percent there was some bad news
on Thursday with the Labor Department
stating that one point eight million
Americans made first-time claims for
unemployment benefits last week that
pushed the number of people who had lost
their jobs amid the pandemic above 42
million weekly jobless claims totaled
one point eight seven seven million
doubt Jones analysts an estimated a job
loss of one point seven seven five
million so this is all bizarre a lot of
people who are still claiming
unemployment but a lot of jobs were
added to the economy because it turns
out that people are not into being
locked up and losing their jobs forever
and a lot of the people who are on
unemployment have technically been sort
of furloughed right a lot of them went
to their employers and they said if you
could just kind of lay me off so that
I'm eligible to make more money off
unemployment than I am working for you
right now since I am furloughed that
would be great but those people are
gonna get their jobs back
the economy is expected to begin
recovering during the second half of
2020 the CBO's may report had said the
labor market is projected materially
improved after the third quarter but
obviously this was happening earlier
right so bottom line is that people want
to get back to work people are getting
back to work and that is amazing
that is really good news this led Paul
Krugman the expert over at the New York
Times because the experts are always
right this is the thing that we have
learned over the past several months is
you must listen to data you must listen
to the experts you must listen to the
science how does somebody who is kind of
fond of listening to data in science
I've been noting all along that the data
and science have not been backing a lot
of the positions taken by the so called
experts but it is amusing to watch as
Paul Krugman becomes an employment
truther he tweeted out this morning
this being the Trump era you can't
completely discount the possibility
they've gotten to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics they've gotten to them
President Trump went to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics he said it's gonna be
unemployment numbers or your brains and
this piece of paper but it's much more
likely says Paul Krugman that the models
used to produce these numbers have gone
haywire in a time of pandemic he says
these numbers should make you more not
less pessimistic about the economic
outlook why because they'll reinforce
the White House inclination to do
nothing and let emergency aid expire
unbelievable so you get it so you're
wrong by like the swing there from 7.5
million jobs lost you 2.5 million jobs
gained you were off by 10 million jobs
in that swing and your initial response
is this is very bad because it means
that there won't be as much stimulus as
we need or you're just wrong about like
all the things Paul Krugman and you have
been wrong for years this is the same
guy who suggested the internet would not
change the way we did business who'd be
like the fax machine right the genius
Paul Krugman the guy the guy is just
incredible at what he does so that is
very good news people have been saying
on the right is it possible that Trump
can still win given everything that's
going on given the fact that he's
trailing Joe Biden heavily given the
fact that he's trailing in a lot of the
swing states the answer is if the
economy really recovers and if Cova
doesn't kill everybody then by the time
we get to the election the story ain't
gonna be the riots the story is going to
be the economy booming again or the
economy skyrocket again or the I mean
this month we had the greatest jobs
growth since 1939 the economy picking up
again and in the face of that Joe Biden
and his performative woken us because
right now the performative openness
looks good when you got a lot of people
out in the streets and when everybody is
being forced to kneel at the altar
almost literally kneel kneel at the
altar of the proposition that America is
systemically
racist every major corporation putting
out notices about this and Jill Biden
out there are eyeing it in the middle of
rioting and looting right all of that
looks good when President Trump doesn't
look like he's in control but if we get
to November and the actual question is
booming economy versus performative woke
miss from a dead guy in Joe Biden that
is a better race for Donald Trump it is
a better race for Donald Trump so good
economic basically Trump's entire future
in politics rests on an economic
recovery at this point it has to happen
for him if there's no economic recovery
he's toast if there is an economic
recovery then he could win you could win
you know a fairly solid victory in the
electoral college we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that no matter what's
going on in your life there's one thing
one cost that typically is not going to
go down and that is your cell phone bill
right now it's certainly not gonna go
down because you've probably been using
your phone non-stop considering you
can't see other live human beings but
there's one way you can save a ton of
money on your cell phone bill I'm
talking about pure talk USA you can cut
costs and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider pure talk covers 99% of
Americans the president and CEO of pure
talk is a u.s. veteran I know him he's
great he cares deeply about serving
Americans by making wireless affordable
you can start your saving today I've
been using pure talk myself and I'm
looking forward to saving a lot of money
on my cell phone bill style Palin 250
say keyword ben shapiro
for unlimited talk unlimited text two
gigs of data for just 20 bucks a month
plus you get 50% off your first month so
10 bucks a month stop paying too much
too big wireless providers switch to
pure talk today say 50% off your first
month dial pound 250 say the keyword ben
shapiro again dial pound 250 keyword ben
shapiro pure talk at USA simply smarter
wireless you're spending too much money
because you have the unlimited data
that's the reality and pure talk it's
gonna make sure you don't go check them
out right now dial pound 250 say key
word ben shapiro your coverage is just
as good as with any other company and
again you're not gonna pay a fortune
tile pound 250 say the key word ben
shapiro
to get started okay so meanwhile in the
in the rioting news in the and the
looting news and the protest news the
big story of the evening and of the
morning was this video there's a lot of
video that's coming out right now of the
police being brutal to people and this
is bad and all the officers involved
should be punished when they are brutal
the people obviously the police have a
really rough job that does not alleviate
them of their responsibility to not
involve themselves in
of police brutality we have seen this
happen a bunch of times so there was
there is a situation that happened in
Buffalo New York yesterday in which an
elderly man apparently 75 years old
approached police officers who's a
protester and he and he is pushed he
loses his balance and he smacks his head
against the pavement medics come forward
and treat him they put him in ambulance
he was taken away the man's name is
Martin who Gino he's in a bam hearse
who's in serious but stable condition
apparently with a concussion and
lacerations the officers were seen
walking past him as he lay bleeding on
the ground and then they went they
arrested somebody who was behind him who
apparently was not leaving when they
were supposed to leave the Buffalo mayor
Byron Brown issued a statement saying he
was deeply disturbed by the video the
officers were suspended without pay the
Governor Andrew Cuomo of course called
the incident wholly unjustified not only
disgraceful which it is I just wish that
Andrew Cuomo were quite as quite as
upset about you know mass rioting and
looting in the middle of New York City
you can do both right I'm not upset with
the the tweet about this being
unjustified in disgrace well I'm more
upset that he allowed people to run
roughshod through his major city for
seven complete days and seven complete
nights like that that seems like that
was a bad policy but with that said
there are there a few points you made
here one police brutality is a thing
that happens it is a thing that happens
there are police who are brutal and
right now because all the cameras are
out and every police officer in America
is out you're gonna see more instances
of that and that being caught on camera
and police officers being punished for
this sort of thing I think most police
officers are on board with that in this
particular case the shove is bad the
dick the guy obviously does lose his
balance and he trips over himself don't
shove 75 year old people is the answer
to this particular problem the guys
white can we've seen other cases there
was a case in Washington DC when the
when SWAT was attempting to disperse a
crowd and one SWAT member just goes
right after a cameraman there's a
cameraman who's standing right there and
you see the SWAT guy take his shield and
just slam the shield into the stomach of
the cameraman the cameraman is white
he's from Australia why do I mention the
race because the narrative that we are
being told by the black lives matter
crew is that police brutality is
reserved for black people but the issue
here is not bad police training and
police brutality and incidents thereof
but generalize systemic American racism
I've suggested that typically when you
have incidents of police brutality it's
really more an issue of the fact that a
lot of police are not well trained a lot
of police are too aggressive that that
happen
across communities it is not relegated
to the black community and that to
pretend that every incidence of
brutality is in fact an incidence of
racism is to make a category error in
fact everybody who's jumping to the
conclusion that the Darracq shavon
killing of of George Floyd the alleged
killing of George Floyd and I say
alleged because again there's
conflicting autopsies on this but the
alleged killing of George Floyd by
Derrick Sheldon people who are jumping
to the conclusion that Shelvin did that
because he's a brutal racist as opposed
to because he's just not a good cop and
was involved in incidents of police
brutality and with badly trained the
jump there is not supported by the
evidence in that particular case now
there are cases in which there is
evidence to support the racism charge so
a perfect case in which where you have
evidence to support a racism charge
would be the awkward are bury case so
originally I said maybe this is just
vigilantes who were who were attempting
to stop what they thought was a crime
and they were wrong and they're acting
like idiots and and bad people and they
got into an armed confrontation with our
Barry and shot him which means they
should go to jail but that is not a case
necessarily of racism well now we
actually have evidence so now looks more
like racism right so when you follow the
evidence the nice thing about evidence
is it doesn't tend to bring you to the
wrong conclusion more data is generally
good knowing the motivations of people
is generally going to be more helpful in
generating data for a narrative than
simply just assuming the narrative and
what you're seeing from the black lives
matter movement what you're seeing from
the media is and when you're seeing from
every major corporation every major
corporation in America is now saying
I've donated a million dollars to the
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund in
acknowledgement of systemic racism by
the way if you think that those sorts of
donations are going to now alleviate
people calling you racist if you're a
major corporation you're wrong it's not
going to happen right if the Amazon
thinks that by putting up a black lives
matter banner on their website that
people are going to now just pretend
that Amazon is fine that the left is
going to leave Amazon alone good luck
with that right really like enjoy okay
but the reality is that in certain cases
you can actually tell whether racism is
happening so there is an allegation now
that Travis McMichael 34 called the
alleged victim Okumura berry in that
Georgia awful awful awful case right
they're not being charged with murder
Travis McMichael who is one of the
shooters called the alleged victim in
effing n-word after the shoot
before police arrived according to
testimony from Special Agent Richard
Dyle
that came second hand from a
co-defendant William Roddy Bryan 50 the
man who recorded video of the fatal
shooting now this has been called a
little bit into question because the guy
was recording the shooting from behind
he was in his car so unless he yelled it
the question is how the guy in the car
heard it but assuming that he's not
lying assume he's not trying to you know
get off the hook by basically saying
this was a racist murder and I wasn't
involved in any ways the racism but
assuming it's true which I don't see why
we shouldn't assume it's true assuming
it's true that is a case of a racist
murder right
so yes racism exists yes we can identify
it and yes we can punish it but to
immediately assume that every that every
incident of police brutality involving a
black person is really about the race of
the black person as opposed to the
police brutality I think is a fairly
major category error but we are not
really supposed to talk about the
category error because again there is a
narrative to be driven and the narrative
is that America is deeply evil and
deeply terrible in every possible way
and this is why you see senators
kneeling at the at the US Capitol okay
that now again the kneeling symbol is I
don't know if it's deliberately vague or
if it's obviously supposed to be the
Colin Kaepernick thing right that was
the symbol that Colin Kaepernick used
Colin Kaepernick the former 49ers
quarterback got benched and then decided
to kneel and work socks with cops his
pigs on them he was kneeling for the
national anthem and for the American
flag because of police brutality the
implication being that America broadly
writ is guilty for the sins of police
brutality and racism is to blame for all
police brutality now you have the United
States sitting senators who are kneeling
in honor of George Floyd well if the
idea is that you have to accept that
America is systemically racist then
that's a very bad thing for the country
it's suggesting that America is
systemically here's the problem with
making arguments like institutionally
racist or systemically racist they are
deliberately nonspecific and they are
deliberately created so that you can
never alleviate them I don't like
problems that you can never alleviate
especially in politics right it's it's
it's it's a serious issue because first
of all if it's not if you're not able to
alleviate it then you really shouldn't
concern yourself with it in politics
right if if something in politics is not
alleviate able then sometimes the
solution is worse than the care this is
true with regard to for example income
inequality if you want to solve income
inequality you could go full comi and
everybody can have the exact same income
but that is not an alleviate able
problem in which the the solution is not
worse than the problem if you say
systemic racism you never actually have
to cite the policy you think is racist
or point to the person you think is
racist instead you just say everything
is racist and as I said yesterday that's
a religious belief it is not an actual
specific belief about something that we
can fix right that's just racism is out
there in the atmosphere who's the racist
I don't know maybe it's you maybe it's
you well but I'm not a racist I've never
done anything racist well maybe it's
implicit maybe you don't even know
you're doing the racist in what can you
name the racist thing I've done no can
you name the racist thing that I believe
no can you name any of the racist things
that I'm responsible for no but deep
down in your heart without you even
knowing it you're probably racist okay
well now you have made an allegation
that is completely unfalsifiable
suggesting systemic racism or
institutional racism is deliberately
nonspecific and if you want to talk
about policy you want to talk about
redlining for example back in the 1960s
which was a thing and was made illegal
in 1975 right if you by the federal
government if you want to talk about
informal practices of redlining which by
the way are illegal and by the way you
could sue banks over then you're talking
about a policy that has been alleviated
by law if you want to talk about the
fact that his that history has
consequences that of course is true but
the question is what do you want to do
about that today because I can't go back
I don't have a time machine I can't go
back in time and change stuff that
happened in the past so what policy
would you like to pursue today that is
going to alleviate the problem of quote
unquote systemic racism and if your
suggestion is that we have to do
injustice today in order to rectify the
in justices of the past the answer is no
because now you're just doing in
justices today two wrongs do not
actually make a right nor do they leave
you at the problem if anybody thinks
that slavery reparations that signing
checks to descendants of slaves people
are gonna go okay I guess we're done
here
systemic racism fixed good luck with
that it's not going to happen
Natalia he see Coates as admitted as
much in his seminal essay the case for
reparations very late in the essay he
says maybe it won't work but we should
just give it a try well know if your
entire cases that the reparations are
reparative if you're saying it might not
work then it's not reparative that's not
if you go to a mechanic and the mechanic
says you know I'm gonna need to complete
I'm gonna charge you the worth of the
car all you need to do and it might fix
your car it might not fix your car are
you gonna go to that mechanic I have
serious doubts I have serious doubts
okay so we're gonna talk more about the
black lives matter
because it's not clear exactly what
people are stumping for other than that
generalized sense of America being bad
which is something that you as an
American should oppose we'll get to that
in a second first let's talk about the
fact that everybody needs a good sofa
you're spending an awful lot of time
home on that sofa these days and if
you're listening to the show for a while
you've heard me talk about my helix
mattress which is just spectacular so I
have great news for you
Hewitt's has gone beyond the bedroom
they've started making sofas they just
launched a new company it's called all
form they're making a premium
customizable sofa and chairs shipped
directly to your door so what makes all
form sofas really awesome for starters
it's the easiest way you can customize
the stuff like using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain and scratch resistant which
is great for me I have a little kids so
they're gonna ruin everything but not
this the sofa color the color of the
legs sofa size shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home and
they've got arm chess and love seats all
the way up to an 8 seat sectional so
there's someone there's something for
everyone you can only start small and
then you can add on ranking build it
like LEGO pieces and you just build an
entire living room set off alarm sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping in the past if you
wanted to order so if I could take weeks
or months to arrive and you need someone
to come and assemble it in your home all
form takes three to seven days to arrive
in the mail and you can assemble it
yourself in just a few minutes no tools
needed I have an arm sofa it is on its
way I cannot wait my wife is super
excited about it if getting a sofa
without trying it in the store sounds
risky don't worry you get a hundred days
to decide if you actually want to keep
it that's more than three months and if
you don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund and have
a forever warranty literally forever so
I mean this is like an amazing just as
good as helix stuff is all for him is
just as good and it's for sofas which
you're gonna be on a lot of your time
basically helix can solve all your
furniture needs like go over to all form
right now go check them out right now at
all format comm slash men to find your
perfect sofa right now all form is
offering 20% off all orders for our
listeners at all four mat.com slash pen
use that slash ban all form dot-com
slash man al l fo RM comm slash men okay
so what does the black lives matter
movement one so if you're talking about
specific policies the answer is that the
BLM agenda is posted on their website is
completely insane I mean it's things
like defund the police free Palestine
like it's just it's radical radical
stuff and if you don't remember the
agenda all you have to do is go back to
2014 when it was the exact same agenda
that nobody actually wanted to adopt so
what exactly is driving all of this
what's driving a lot of this
is the pitch which is that America is
deliberately keeping black people down
now I have a generalized view of human
beings they don't think about each other
all that much they don't spend an awful
lot of time thinking about keeping other
people down not in America okay in
America there are not very many people
who get up in the morning and like you
know what I'm keeping a black guy down
today I really don't think there are a
lot of those people so if they're not a
lot of those people and you can't psych
those people then you need to cite me
the rule the rule that's keeping black
people down and if you can't cite me a
rule then I'm not sure exactly what we
are supposed to do about your accusation
if instead what is actually happening is
the generalized leftist pitch that any
inequality can be chalked up to
injustice even if you can't name the
injustice I'm not gonna go along with
that if the idea is that any inequality
that income inequality can be chalked up
to some sort of exploitation or
historical grievance that can only be
cured by some new injustice no the
answer is no I'm not gonna go along with
that and if you're going to imply that
Americans are bad hearted and racist and
that the only way to alleviate this is
the expiation of sin through quasi
religious rituals in which you kneel and
repeat after people the answer is no
that is one American that is not
something I'm willing to do as a free
American who has not sinned against
black people that is not something I'm
willing to do I'm perfectly willing to
accept my own sins I have a full list on
my website of things I feel I've said
wrong over the course of my career but
I'm not willing to accept responsibility
for something that my non ancestors did
and I'm not willing and nobody else
should either just as a black person
should not be forced to accept
responsibility for things that black
people do that are wrong white people
should not be forced to accept
responsibility for things that white
people do that are wrong or have done in
the past if you are looking to fix
things what you there's a basic role in
marriage and basic rule in marriage is
when you're having an argument
don't say you always act right you
always treat me like this you know this
is like the first rule of marital
counseling why because it's not specific
it's not a problem you can solve and
usually it's inaccurate because people
don't always do anything instead you
have to you have to say what is the
exact problem that we have and how do we
solve this problem that is right in
front of us if you are just going to
suggest without evidence and every
single instance of police brutality is
indicative of broader American racism
and by the way every instance of a black
person killing a white person is not
indicative of a bigger problem it's just
an individual incident but every
instance of a white person killing a
black person is indicative a broader
American historical races
none of this follows none of this files
and it does not help when you tried out
spokespeople like Al Sharpton the worst
race baiter of modern American history
al Sharpton completely falsified a rape
case about Tawana Brawley al Sharpton
was involved in inciting the riots in my
opinion in Crown Heights in 1991 that
ended with the murder of an Orthodox Jew
he literally went out in front of a
crowd and said that if he wanted if a
Jew on to fight him pin back your
yarmulke and come on over right Al
Sharpton was involved in the incitement
of the burning of Freddy's fashion Mart
in my opinion again in New York City in
1996 when he suggested that Jewish
interlopers were taking over real estate
in New York that guy be and I think I I
mean his ish stick is that he goes to
businesses he claims that they're
racists and then if they sign a check to
his fund they he leaves them alone this
is Al Sharpton schtick
so am I gonna listen to him nobody has
made more money off of the lie of
systemic American racism the now
Sharpton nobody has made more money off
of it than al Sharpton so using him as
your spokesperson is a mistake so al
Sharpton yesterday made a statement in
which he suggested that ever since 401
years ago the reason we could never be
who he wants and in dreamed of being is
you kept your knee on our neck for 400
years now Americans literally kept their
knees on the necks of black people all
the way up to the Civil War and then in
the South through Jim Crow but el
Sharpton has had no one's knee on his
neck al Sharpton has made a very very
lucrative career out of blackmailing
people so that he would leave them alone
he says we were smarter than the
underfunded schools you put us in but
you had your knee on our neck we could
run corporations and not hustle on the
street but you had our knee on our neck
okay what is what is the policy knee so
we can all be on the same page what is
the policy need that is on the neck of
black people right now if you can't name
it then I'm gonna have a hard time
taking very seriously Al Sharpton's
contentions this is the problem that I
have with this program if you want to
march against police brutality cops are
marching against police brutality
everybody is against police brutality
but the vigor of the charge the harder
it is to rebut and that I think is the
purpose that is the goal here the vigor
the charge the harder it is to Rabat and
that is why vague charges are being made
so Keanu Mariah Ross a professor of
African American Studies has a piece of
the New York Times called call it what
it is
anti-blackness she said it's not racism
she said the right term is anti
blackness just to be clear racism isn't
a meaningless term but it's a catch-all
that can encapsulate anything for
black people being denied fair access to
mortgage loans to Asian students being
burned burdened with a model minority
label it's not specific anti-blackness
is one way some black scholars have
articulated what it means to be marked
as black in an anti black world it's
more than just racism against black
people that oversimplifies and dfangs it
it's a theoretical framework that
illuminates society's inability to
recognize our humanity that is stain
disregard and disgust for our existence
ok evidence please evidence
seriously disdain disregard and disgust
for our existence we have active
affirmative action programs at every
major American University because there
is not disdain disregard and disgust for
the existence of black people there's a
desperate attempt to help black people
in bad circumstances move up the move up
the ladder of success but the basic
notion in America that that anti
blackness is the defining feature
that'll again allows you to lay
everything at the feet of none
unspecified enemy and then we get in
this column the usual trick we're gonna
go back 150 years to slavery and then
we're just gonna fast forward as though
nothing has changed in the interim anti
blackness describes the inability to
recognize black humanity it captures the
reality that the kind of violence that
saturates black life is not based on any
specific thing a black person better
described as a person who has been
racialized black did what does that even
mean the violence we experience isn't
tied to any particular transgression
it's gratuitous and unrelenting anti
blackness covers the fact that society's
hatred of blackness and also its
gratuitous violence against black people
is complicated by its need for our
existence for example for white people
again better described as those who have
been racialized white this is an easy
way by the way of dismissing black
conservatives and treating white
liberals as though they are woke the
abject inhumanity of the black
reinforces their whiteness their
humanist and their power their privilege
whether or whether they're aware of it
or not is my favorite part whether
they're aware of it or not okay so now
we're ghost hunting now we are your
racist even if you don't know you're
racist I can't explain why you're a
racist but I know you are because
whether you're aware of it or not I know
that out there there's a bunch of people
who are just anti black and the fact
that you exist is evidence as a white
person that anti blackness exists like
that the vagary is the enemy of unity if
you want people to come together you
have to make a specific proposal if you
want people to actually move beyond a
problem you have to make a specific
proposal for a solution that's what's so
irritating about this because the only
specific proposals I've seen things like
limiting qualified immunity or stopping
police unions from negotiating bad
contracts
I agree with those okay but nobody wants
to actually acknowledge that the right
agrees on a lot of those points so
instead it's well if you don't agree on
the broader point that America is
broadly speaking racist then you're part
of the problem now it seems to me that a
big part of the problem here is the
deliberate attempt to paint a vague
picture of what the problem is in the
first place such that the goalposts can
move ad nauseam they can just move
randomly everything becomes racist so
long as people on the Left suggest that
it is racist and the goalposts
consistently received it doesn't like
perfect example college campuses the
reality is that on college campuses
there are no no place in America has
more accusations of racism than college
campuses these are also the most woke
places on the planet so if you think
that acknowledging white privilege which
is like the dreg or move on campuses
that if acknowledging white privilege on
America's college campuses has somehow
alleviated the problem of accusations of
racism or alleviated racism itself I beg
to differ there is no evidence of this
whatsoever because again the problem is
being used as a club and again the
problem is not even being specifically
explained what is the problem and don't
tell me bad things happening to black
people is the problem bad things happen
to everybody and if the question is why
they happen and how we alleviate the
problem if you can't specify exactly
where the problem is coming from better
than racism or anti blackness that
nobody knows about and I can't have a
policy and I can't name a person I can't
name who did the bad thing if somebody
came to your house and if you call the
police and let's assume a world in which
the police are good okay like they
normally are hey you call the police and
somebody and and and they come to your
door and they say okay what's the
problem and you say the problem is a bad
thing just happened mean they say okay
what's the bad thing that happened to
you and you can't really specify the bad
thing that happened to you and you can't
specify who did it you can't spy's
specified what exactly happened what are
you supposed to do is this a
problem-solving routine or is this just
an expression of venting of spleen and
inequality and inequality is a reality
but it is not necessarily a it is not
necessarily in inequity okay so that by
the way they worth noting that anybody
who thinks that the problem is
alleviated by accepting your white
privilege is full of it right bill de
blasio
spent the entire last week allowing
rioting and looting to overtake his city
his daughter was arrested at a protest
and he said he was proud of her
bill de blasio has spent he said full
speeches talking about his evil horrible
white privilege bill de blasio got booed
at a vigil for George Floyd yesterday so
well done on buying off everybody who
you thought was going to appreciate your
newfound Vulcanus
first lady sure pray pray respect
[Music]
okay so this is Latha rally have to be
have to be told to respect the mayor who
is the woke aspire in America so well
done everybody
problem solved right problem solved
what's hilarious the Democrats made the
pitch that America is systemically
racist that they can't name who's doing
the racism or what the policy is just
elect us and we'll alleviate it has it
been alleviated in New York has been
alleviated in Washington DC has it been
alleviated in LA all Democrats governing
it I haven't noticed
ok meanwhile the performative woke crowd
has taken over major American
institutions the culture wars are
ongoing and the culture wars are bloody
hey there there are people like me we've
been speaking on college campuses for a
long time and pointing out the problems
that exist on America's college campuses
for a long time particularly the
problems of of safe spaces and
microaggressions and if you say
something I don't like you're hurting me
and you're creating a danger and there's
a general attempt by many in the media
and by many on the Left cancel culture
doesn't exist cancel culture isn't real
well it turns out that it actually is
and not only that there are bunch of
people on the right like well is it
really a problem that it's happening on
campuses after all these kids will want
to enter the real world and in the real
world they won't be able to get away
with this bullcrap in the real world
they will actually have to undertake to
understand opposing points you well some
of us have been warning you that what
starts in academia doesn't stay in
academia and that the ridiculous social
justice warrior censorious culture was
good was not just gonna stay in the
Academy was going to leave and take over
the institutions and that the malleus
Cultural Revolution that you are seeing
and America's major institutions is
ongoing it's so hilarious by the way
half of the vox writing team is now
realizing the canceled culture exists
they spent like years denying that it
exists not seeing in the last day half
of the writers over at vox a very
left-wing publication say oh by the way
this cancel culture thing it's not great
it's not great why well because of what
just happened over at the New York Times
I'm gonna explain what happened over at
the New York Times and it is a perfect
and ridiculous example of how when you
start with the premise that America is
systemically evil and that America is
systemically racist and then you suggest
that America
right rights to free speech rights to
freedom of expression that those rights
fall unequally on people because of the
innate and inequality in American life
then all you have to do is curb those
rights and make the rights available
only to people who have been
historically victimized that's that's
the injustice that has to be done today
to correct for the in justices of the
past this is a case first made by err
bear Marquess the radical Marxist
professor from the 1960s when he
suggested that what you really needed
what you really needed was repression of
opposing viewpoints he called it
repressive tolerance you need repressive
tolerance you need a situation in which
tolerance of the left-wing viewpoint is
exacerbated and intolerance of
right-wing viewpoints is put down
because that has to be silenced because
freedom of speech is actually bad is if
the right people if people who are bad
use freedom of speech those people could
actually win so we have to silence those
people such that marginalized voices can
speak made that perspective and and
allowing the non marginalized voices to
speak allowing right-wingers to speak is
a threat to your life that perspective
has taken over the New York Times we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the most
delicious gift you can get for your dad
this Father's Day I know because they
sent me some kosher steaks I'm talking
about Omaha Steaks Omaha's world-famous
steaks
they've been naturally aged for at least
21 days the aging makes the taste I mean
it's unbelievable for tenderness and
hand carved to perfection they offer
tasty easy to make side dishes artisan
desserts and much much more Omaha Steaks
have been America's original butcher
since 1970 we're talking like caramel
apple tart lids
they've got pork tile they got all sorts
of stuff that I wish I didn't keep
kosher so I could actually take
advantage of but they actually did send
me some kosher steaks and they are
magnificent Omaha Steaks delivers
guaranteed quality and safety with every
order all backed by an unconditional
100% money-back guarantee every Omaha
Steaks order is flash-frozen
vacuum sealed delivered in a cooler with
dry ice that means fresh so if you're
looking for the perfect Father's Day
gift Omaha Steaks can help we all know
dad doesn't want another Thai dad wants
steak he's your father
damn it get him the steak that he wants
right now Omaha Steaks is offering my
listeners access to a variety of amazing
packages perfect to send for Father's
Day go to Omaha Steaks comm enter codes
Shapiro in the search bar so I'm not
saving for my listeners remember you got
to go to the search bar and answer
Shapiro and then you'll get savings up
to 50% and more and free shipping on
orders over ninety nine bucks there are
lots of packages available there already
to be sure
straight to your door in time for
Father's Day go to Omaha Steaks calm
enter the code Shapiro that it's Omaha
Steaks calm
enter code Shapiro in the search parts
of shop for Father's Day today alright
we're gonna get to the the unbelievable
takeover of the New York Times editorial
board basically Nicola Hannah Jones is
now the editor of the New York Times I
mean that's that's essentially what we
have realized she's not one of the
editors she is the editor and she's
determining all policy the woke staff at
the New York Times and this is happening
at a lot of major companies have you've
been noticing a lot of the major
corporations issuing statements that's
because they have a lot of woke interns
who are basically telling them that if
they don't then they're gonna be very
very angry at them and the silence is
violence movement is gaining is gaining
speed I actually have so I go to a gym
out here when we're in non pandemic
times the head of the gym emailed me
yesterday and said he had received a
cancellation from somebody not because
he had said anything bad but because he
did not put out a corporate statement
about black lives matter in the middle
of this so the person like he found the
one person who's apparently sitting at
home going I need corporate virtue
signaling or I will not patronize your
business ridiculous okay we're gonna get
to this in just one second first 2020
remember that Donald Trump was actually
impeached this year you know how long
this year has been like so long the
talent Trump was impeached this year and
that was 120 70 years ago that's how
long this year has been we have seen an
impeachment we have seen presidential
debates we have seen Bernie Sanders
climb to the top of the rankings and
collapse we have seen a global pandemic
we have seen race riots in our streets
we have seen we've seen virtually all
the things you can see but the year is
not even halfway over guys years not
even halfway over like it's right now
about halfway so um if you want to keep
track of all of this and you and you
want to make sure the mainstream media
is not cutting off your ability to see
all of the news then you want to check
out daily wire go ahead on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribed get a daily
where our membership for 15% off using
coupon code Shapiro if you join us an
all access memory get to count them two
glorious leftist ears tumblers facts do
not care about your feelings gang also
now is a great time to pre-order my book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps as I said yesterday um when I
wrote this book I was fairly certain it
would be relevant and then the pandemic
and it's like I'm not sure it's gonna be
relevant people seem to be coming
together and then it's super relevant
because the entire book is about how
America is coming apart at the seams
because if a moded grew ammo
evaded group of social justice warriors
and what I call disintegration is people
who are determined to destroy America's
common philosophy and suggest that it is
evil
suggest that our culture of rights is
discriminatory and destroy our common
history and suggest that instead America
be divvied up by racial and
socio-economic group and then destroyed
from the inside that's the that's the
book the entire book is about this it's
rebutting a lot of those contentions it
discusses American history with all the
wars but why America is the greatest
country on planet earth and why if we
don't start believing that again we are
toast the book is called how to destroy
America in three easy steps I think it's
deeply important I get a lot of
questions from people how can i educate
myself about American history how can i
educate myself about American philosophy
how do the Declaration the Constitution
the book has all of these things it
gives you the education you need it
isn't just a diatribe about the badness
of people trying to tear the country
apart it is a in it is an explanation of
why they are wrong and why America is
truly an incredible incredible country
why we need to get back to what was
supposed to unify us in the first place
and over history failed to unify us
because people strayed from those
principles go check it out how to
destroy America in three easy steps it's
coming out July 21st you can pre-order
it right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
radio show and podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the the move toward
America is evil systemically racist and
therefore the only way to fix that
systemic racism is to shut down all the
voices we don't like that movies being
made by the New York Times staff by the
woke staff at the New York Times and
understand they don't actually think
that right-wing perspectives are quote
unquote violent they don't they don't
actually think that I think there are
some of them who do some of them are so
delusional but they believe that if they
print an editorial from Tom cotton that
is actual violence to people and I think
most of them just don't like the
viewpoint and they're using the excuse
of your viewpoint is inherently unjust
an unjust viewpoint means that you're
exacerbating the systemic inequalities
of the United States therefore we have
every right to ban what you are saying
and every obligation not just right
every obligation to ban what you are
saying so it is not really a threat of
violence it is the belief that the only
way to make a better America is to
repress voices that you don't like and
listen every publication has editorial
standards but if you are saying that you
cannot print an op-ed from the sitting
United States Senator Tom cotton a
Harvard Law graduate who is writing a
piece served in the military writing a
piece about the use of the military
against rioting and looting if you point
by the way agreed to by polling data by
6 and 10 Americans you cannot run that
piece and that it's bad to run that
piece you are not only not in the
mainstream you are fully insane you are
fully crazy ok but that is the the way
that a lot of these organizations are
being run we saw the same thing with the
Atlantic that organization run by the
execrable Jeffrey Goldberg hired Kevin
Williamson from National Review to write
and then after some woke staffers
decided to Kevin Williamson was bad bad
they fired him well now you're seeing
this over at the New York Times so
yesterday there was a big brouhaha
because Tom cotton wrote this op-ed
suggesting that it was time to send in
the troops to restore order during
rioting and looting he was he did make a
distinction between protesters and
rioters and looters but people at the
New York Times don't make that
distinction because they think that the
rioters and looters are justified in
tearing down the institutions of
American privilege so a bunch of members
of the New York Times woke staff tweeted
out the same thing as I mentioned
yesterday they all did the college
dissol College bullcrap it's all College
bullcrap I've been on enough campuses to
know this I visited dozens and dozens
produces over the course of the last
four years they all do this ok it's
ridiculous
these can
bizarre replete with this kind of woken
nonsense and one of the things that they
do is I mentioned yesterday is the if
you agree with somebody can't clap cause
it might it might trigger somebody's
post-traumatic stress disorder so
instead you're supposed to slap
something and you're supposed to repeat
slogans so if somebody says something
then you're supposed to just like you
saw it that DeBlasio rally you somebody
from the microphones has respect and you
don't just give respect you're supposed
to shout back respect or at the Bethesda
Maryland thing you're supposed to repeat
sentence by sentence what somebody is
telling you which is a religious woke
incantation okay so the entire New York
Times staff apparently decides to tweet
out the same thing running this puts a
black New York Times staff in danger in
danger if you're a black writer for the
New York Times
Tom cotton saying that using American
military to put down riots is putting
black staff at the New York Times in
danger why are they rioting and looting
are they flinging Molotov cocktails and
cop cars if not they probably shouldn't
feel super endangered by this but this
became such an issue that the New York
Times they didn't pull down the peas
they didn't issue a correction to these
instead they issued a statement and here
was their statement from their
spokeswoman we've examined the piece and
the process leading up to its
publication this review made clear that
a rush to editorial process led to
publication of an op-ed that did not
meet our standards as a result we're
planning to examine both short term and
long term changes to include expanding
our fact-checking operation and reducing
the number of op eds we publish so
they're actually printing fewer op eds
because some woke staffers who are not
willing to quit by the way if it was
such a danger they should've quit I've
quit publications where I think the
publication is doing something deeply
and terribly wrong I've done it myself
none of these woke staffers were willing
to quit the New York Times over
apparently running a piece so dangerous
it was putting their own staffs lives in
danger
none of them are willing to quit they're
just willing to about it to upper
management that the pusillanimous
cowardly upper management would
apologize for running a piece that 58%
of Americans agree with really well done
well done by the way how do you know
they're lying you know they're lying
because it's 27 hours later 29 hours
later it said this thing's been up for I
think nearly two days maybe 48 hours
later they still have not issued a
correction on the piece so if the piece
was factually wrong where's the
correction they stole them pulled it
down and so up so this was just please
please don't please don't yell at us
please don't yell it isn't so bad why
are you yelling at us we're whoa we're
woke the New York Times staffers
they were leaking to other publications
news that people were canceling their
subscriptions Wow
oh man first of all I thought that
generally speaking you don't want your
staffers leaking to outside publications
that's just not something that is done
if I found my staffers of the daily
where leaking doubts I'd publications
about internal business at the Daily
where they're fired like this that's how
fast they are fired it's my company it's
my business okay but they had staffers
who are leaking this stuff out and the
staffers were leaking out amazing
amazing news news like 200 people
canceled their subscriptions inside of
one hour whew 200 people
well if 200 people did a thing that
means that probably the 1 million New
York Times subscribers by the way I
think that's an underestimate it may be
2 million New York Times subscribe
clearly they're all cancelling on mass
the amount of cowardice in corporate
America even including in our press and
especially in our press is it's stunning
you want to know why peloton is sending
out little notices about wool culture
because they're afraid they might
receive 10 tweets that's why because all
of these corporations are cowardly and
so they've decided they're going to bow
to the notion of systemic racism by the
way what they don't understand is they
are signing the death warrant for their
own for their own companies because the
whoa culture is not satisfied with you
making prata stations of your innocence
or of your guilt once you say that you
are once you say that you are
responsible for systemic racism do you
think it stops with that admission or do
you think that now you're on the hook
for every claim that people who claim
that you are the problem are gonna make
the admission of guilt is not is not an
alleviation of your responsibility
according to these folks you the
admission of guilt is the first step
toward them wrecking you this is how
these apologies work is how these
apologies work so Barry Weiss who is one
of the only sane people within your our
times I don't know how she's lasted
there that long I don't think she'll
last much longer to be frank with you
given the nature of the situation at the
New York Times she tweeted out the civil
war inside the New York Times between
the mostly young folks wokes versus the
mostly 40-plus liberals is the same one
raging inside other publications and
companies across the country the dynamic
is always the same the old guard lives
by a set of principles we can broadly
call civil libertarianism they assumed
that shared world they shared that
worldview with the young people they
hired who called themselves liberals and
progressives this was an incorrect
the new guard has a different world view
one articulated best by John Hyde and
Greg lukianov they call it safety ISM in
which the right of people to feel
emotionally and psychologically safe
trumps were previously considered core
liberal values like free speech I'm in
no way surprised by what has now
exploded into public view in a way it's
oddly comforting I feel less alone in
less crazy trying to explain the dynamic
to people what I am shocked by is the
speed I thought it would take a few
years not a few weeks here's one way to
think about what's at stake the New York
Times motto is all the news that's fit
to print
one group emphasizes the word all the
other emphasizes the word fit okay this
is correct naturally every one of the
New York Times like that that's not
happening that's not happening max
Strasser is I'm in the same meeting
Barry is live tweeting this is
inaccurate in both characterizations
it's not a civil war it's an editorial
conversation oh it's an editorial
conversation that ends with you
restricting your op-ed page not pulling
down a piece that supposedly is
chock-full of errors by the way for the
New York Times to say that their
fact-checking is bad on Tom cotton piece
this is the same newspaper that printed
the 16:19 project and made the
suggestion that virtually everything in
the American Revolution was designed to
preserve slavery which is insane insane
fully insane than one appeal it's are
for their trouble pinched souls burger
the the idiot publisher of the New York
Times he put out a statement saying I've
already heard from any of you I will do
more listening in the days of head there
will be a town hall tomorrow a town hall
about running an op-ed from a sitting
American senator they've run out beds
from Vladimir Putin they've run out beds
about why sex is better in communist
countries and they can't run an op-ed
from Tom cotton saying that maybe you
might need to use the military to put
down civil insurrection like this is
it's crazy it's crazy he says I believe
in the principle of openness to a range
of opinions even those who may disagree
with this piece was published in that
spirit but it's essential we listen and
reflect on the concerns we're hearing as
we would with any piece that is the
subject of significant criticism so just
absolute absolute cowardice okay how bad
is the canceled culture how bad is the
since aureus culture there is a piece in
The Washington Post today by Alisa
Rosenberg who is one of the the TV
columnist and sometimes writes
interesting stuff this is not one of
those times she has a piece titled shut
down all police movies and TV shows now
so the police are so bad that we should
all stop watching law and order because
the police are
we should all stop watching any show or
movie that portrays the police as good
because we all know the police are
actually brutal and racist now first of
all if you think there has not been a TV
show or movie made about police
brutality and racism let me recommend
every single police show ever made
except for Law & Order and maybe dragnet
every show made since NYPD Blue has
taken on these issues every single one
all of them but Alisa Rosenberg suggests
that we have a generalized view of the
police is good and that's bad and that
needs to stop she says for a century
Hollywood has been collaborating with
police departments telling stories that
whitewash whitewashed police shootings
and valorizing an action hero style of
policing over the harder less dramatic
work of building relationships with the
communities cops are meant to serve and
protect purely from a dramatic
perspective crime makes his story seem
consequential investigating crime
genre's actions solving crime provides
for morally and emotionally satisfying
conclusion the result is an addiction to
stories that portray Police Department
and is more effective than they actually
are crime is more prevalent than it
actually is and police use of force has
consistently justified and then she says
we should cancel dick Wolf's Chicago
franchise of shows we should get rid of
Law & Order SVU we should get rid of all
of the shows that you like watching
because obviously they are training you
that the police are good instead we
should all watch Brooklyn nine-nine
because it's a reformist police show
it's very very important one way one
white Ford might be to emphasize the
dialogues and sometimes fear struggles
that take place within police
departments the shield follows the rain
and eventual downfall of corrupt
detective Vic Mackey's she likes the
shield and she likes the wire but those
are the only ones and even the shield
took too long to get to the point where
the cops are actually bad we need we
need only shows where the cops are bad
now I have a question should we also ban
rap music so for a long time there was
this idea and it came from some elements
of the right and some elements of left
that rap music was causing people to be
violent right video games also causing
people to be violent then there's a bevy
of social science and it's read not so
much okay so now we have a piece in The
Washington Post suggesting we stop all
police movies and TV shows there's a
piece today in the New York Times
talking about how we don't need any more
novels or TV shows about cops who do the
wrong things for the right reason we
need to stop all of that no more hard
charging cops in novels and TV shows we
need to stop all of this instead we need
woke books more woke books that's what
we need
the censorship is how fast is this
taking place incredibly fast because
canceled culture is real it exists it is
ugly it is designed to destroy your
freedoms your freedoms to consume what
you would like your freedom to say what
you would like your freedom to read and
watch what you would like in order so
that all messages must mirror the same
message even if that message is
factually untrue such as that America
was founded on slavery not on freedom or
that America is systemically racist
rotten to the core every message must be
named must be made to match this message
it's not even enough for drew brees to
apologize for saying that the image all
he said was I won't kneel for the
American flag because I had grandfathers
who fought in the military in the
American flag stands for freedom he was
forced to apologize and then who's
forced to apologize again he issued a
second apology today okay there they're
coming for you they're coming to kill
you not literally speaking figuratively
speaking they're coming to finish our
career they're coming at you
and once you apologize for saying
something is anodyne as the American
flag is not worth kneeling for the
American flag is worth much more than
that
that in it they will stop that they'll
never stop shannon sharpe right the the
former tight end for for the Denver
Broncos he says he's never going to
respect drew brees now for having said
that kneeling for the American flag is
bad
here's Shannon Sharpe yesterday drew
brees field doesn't seem to get it now
he issued apology skill but it's
meaningless because the guys know that
he spoke his heart the very first time
around correct I don't know if I'll I
don't know what drew is gonna do but he
promise you can just go ahead and retire
now he it will never be the same what he
said they gonna all yell you know no
they will never look at him the same
because he spoke his heart and skill and
what he said it wasn't what he said is
how he said it he was defiant I will
never respect the man so all respect
he's gone for drew brees for having said
that he likes the American flag once you
apologize did it solve the problem did
it because I'm not getting that
impression once you bow to the
performative whoa crowd once you've
added the social justice warriors there
Joffrey okay kneeling bending the knee
does not amount to an act of unity in
front of social justice warriors who
suggest that America's systemically
raised
Joffre lops off the head of Ned okay
that is what is going to happen for a
country that decides that it is indeed
endemically racist across every aspect
of its humanity they can't explain why
you can't explain the policies you can't
explain the racists you're granting you
are granting a premise that is going to
end the country that is the danger here
not marching in its police brutality
which is fine not marching against
individual instances of racism which is
fine suggesting that America broadly red
is unjust that is a serious problem and
that is a problem that's going to
outlast whatever happens over there over
the course of the next week or so
already we will be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise please I told
you last weekend try not to burn down
the country
well we're gone and for the weekend can
we try that again I take two we'll see
you here next week i'm ben shapiro this
is the bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike pore Amina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 you know the Matt Walsh oh
it's not just another show about about
politics I think there are enough of
those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else so my main
focus is our life family faith those are
fundamental and that's what this show is
about I hope you'll give it a listen